alright what is going on guys before we
get into the video I kind of want to
give you a different little bit of
scenery considering you know i'll be at
the grand exchange to the rest of the
video nonetheless before we get into it
i'd like to say if you guys do enjoy the
content that you guys are saying feel
free to subscribe down below it means a
ton to me i'm watching my follower or my
subscriber count going up every day
probably because my better not is video
but nonetheless if you guys enjoy this
feel free to drop a light to and
obviously this this video is a little
how should i say it's for addict at
times and i understand that i'm going to
try to work on that and further episodes
nonetheless so if you guys liked it feel
free to leave like if there's any
improvement so you guys can make or
anything you want to tell me feel free
to leave that the comments down below
not unless let's get right into the
weird noise i'm about to make where are
the other drugs going alright so i just
woke up it's been a full day and the
occult necklaces finally sold they did
sell for about 15 k less than i bought
all of them for so I didn't lose about
100k we're gonna get back into this I'm
gonna find some items to do and we're
gonna make some money back so I just
found out that Gilda platelegs have a
pretty decent margin actually there's
about 80 k on each one so I'm just gonna
try to flip these for a little while and
then hopefully we can move on to
something else I kind of want to get
away from gilded but it's a very good
item for this price range though so if
you guys are watching this video and you
guys need anything to merge just follow
kind of what I'm doing obviously there
are better ones if you know more stuff
around this price range I'm not too
knowledgeable on it so this is just what
I'm going to do for the time being so
just a preface asst I haven't merged in
about two days because they cold
necklaces just kind of got me down about
merging but I'm so I that these things
bought this quilt I was middle of the I
was in the middle of a game of fifa
decided wait my gilded legs probably
sold and they did so we're gonna go back
and buy them again all right so is at
this point that I decided that I would
go back through and not really do live
com as much I don't know it's just
something that I decided to do at the
time because I thought it would be
easier allowed me to merge more and do
other stuff however looking back on I
don't think that that's the right move
and I'm going to try to keep it with
live com for the rest of the series so
nonetheless hope you guys enjoy the rest
of the video but before I don't know why
I said that I kinda need to get into the
rest of this anyway it's my explanation
as to why I do gilded so much and you
guys will probably see that throughout
this episode and a little bit of the
next because i'm currently merchant it's
an item that there's not enough of in
the game to where the margins are really
low and it's constantly bought and sold
for free to play Piquet and with PK and
free to play peaking i would imagine
especially people don't care what price
they buy and sell it forward they just
want to buy and sell it so realistically
there's always a pretty good margin I
then went on to drive bandos boots
bandos boots I actually had like a seven
k margin but the problem was there I
pretty sure I got undercut and that
happens a lot with items like that I
really wasn't about it then I go on to
the magic Fang the magic Fang was a good
like 40k margin maybe 20 k it wasn't it
wasn't a whole lot but it was something
at the time I mean it's um it's it's an
item that I'm pretty sure just lost all
of its profit because of tour Vesta tour
Vesta has done a lot of merging videos
and it almost does a magic Fang and
pretty much every video so I kind of
ruin to that but Varrick skirts then
we're going for about 15 k i'm pretty
sure later this episode I have a better
viraag skirt merch for about 50 to 75 k
something like that as you can see here
this is actually one of the more
interesting merges that I was doing I
went through and I found the bought and
sold price of all of the gilded so I
could find out what price I could buy
each of the individual pieces at and
what price i could sell the set at and
at the end of it i don't know if it's it
if it i don't believe it's in this clip
however in the end i found out that it
was a 200 to 300 k margin on each one
and i'm pretty sure i made two sets or
maybe three sets after that so i ended
up making back the money that i lost
find the other prices and then i also
went on to make about another 600 k so
it was it was pretty good it wasn't it
wasn't too bad i accidentally just
clicked away so anyways yeah so the
gilded the gilded cage shield actually
ended up at this point having the best
margin it's like I just ended up going
with that for some reason it was like a
30k margin so I figured why not but I
don't think that many of the guild
shields bought so yeah as you can see
there I was Greg so I just cashed out
and now I'm up to you 7.2
I want on to do eternal crystals it's
something I like to do a lot it's just a
really good item but it takes a lot of
time so let's get back into the life so
it seems I have totally [__] up and
buying this eternal crystal I'm going to
try to sell it overnight but I'm not
entirely sure as to what the buy and
sell prices of it realistically I'm not
going to lose too much money on it I
just don't have the big margin that I
initially had so it's kind of depressing
I won't be getting that at all as of now
though if we price check it I'm in world
to sorry about that you're gonna you're
gonna see all that so nonetheless I do
have 7.5 millally really insane and you
know it's really good progress I'll
probably record a little bit tomorrow
and then probably wrap it up for this
video because i'm sure i have more than
enough clips and i'm probably already
over like a mill and a half for this
episode so alright so i actually did
find this out of my main but it was just
because of finding the price of eternal
boots they were six point five mil and a
turtle crystals are currently buying for
four point oh five mil and infinity
boots are 1.7 which means in total to
make the eternal boots it caused 5.75
mill but then you can sell them for 6.5
so you literally make 750k off of each
eternal boot pair that you make I've
already bought one internal crystal on
my main so I know they're buying for
that price so i quickly just put all my
money into this and so now i'm just
going to make eternal boots hopefully i
need to find someone my clan chat that
can make it for me though I don't have
60 rear crafting on my merge or my main
account so I cannot physically make them
myself however this is something that
any of you could do if you guys have a
trustworthy clan or you could have
someone give you like an equal value for
it so you know you're not going to get
scampton even if you do you're still
literally get the same exact amount
nonetheless that's what I'm going to be
doing for hopefully a little bit
hopefully this pie is hopefully we're
able to do it i just i want to be able
to make money off of this so bad it's
gonna help the series of ton so no one's
home so we're gonna get into the live
com for a little bit nonetheless gilded
plate set just bought for 50 60 k took
forever though so i'm gonna say that the
price is actually it's definitely more
than that cuz it didn't abide so
put it in for about this make 190k once
it sells hopefully it sells but yeah
merchant hasn't been going the way I
wanted to I don't know if that was a
voice cracker if I made my voice do that
but either way it's there but yeah so
there were some fails with an eternal
crystal um we won't talk about that ah
alright and there we go we are bag so at
this point I just I don't know I want to
do some smaller merchants this is
actually what a lot of people do with
merchant series they do really small
items but I'm pretty sure they do that
because it allows a series too they'll
it allows them to make videos faster
because stuff like this bison sells
really quick like Zorro scales and death
ruins they they come to you really quick
so you can constantly pretty much be
uploading and it is it is beneficial
however in my case I don't think it's
the best thing to do as you can see
there on the barracks sets I ended up
getting 75k per set which isn't normal
most barrows items tend to be very low
in their merchants just because barrows
items are overly merged and everyone
pretty much does that as a basic um as a
basic merge like everyone's pretty much
into that if you guys see all the stuff
in my inventory that's for another video
of a so just be ready for that i'm going
to start this loop from pet series that
i'm going to be putting out on my main
or with my main account so i don't know
as you can see maybe maybe you know
maybe don't I was doing fenton audits
and so I was like trees in this rain
because Venna Dada stops reason it's
rings and I found there's a hundred 10k
margin on them so I was like all right
I'm gonna merge these for a little bit I
ended up actually marching a few so it's
decently profitable as you can see like
i was able to get a nice for you some
bought and sold overnight um I tried the
treasonous rings out again though the
next day not as good they were back down
to like 10 to 20 k and it was you know
decently depressing but we were able to
make it through the cash tax looking
well I I can't have something to explain
at the end of this video throughout the
video though since I wasn't doing live
com I was very sporadic with my
recording so I didn't miss a lot of
clips as you can see I just randomly
bought a gilded
my bad sorry about that anyways
basically what happened is the next
morning I woke up I put in a bunch of
offers for just random stuff like I
normally do and the Gildan skirt bought
as you can see under the actively traded
price by about I believe 400 k like
maybe 450 so I was like all right this
is going to be a lot of profit but then
I looked up how many gilded set with
skirts are bought and sold on daily and
it's under 10 so I was like all right
this is gonna be something that's gonna
take a long while to eat my money back
on so I decided that it would be in my
best interest to then go and buy the
legs themselves and then make the set
into a leg set because basically by
selling off the skirt and buying the
legs I was only investing 2.4 more mil
into the set itself which I then could
have sold for i believe about five point
oh yeah as you can see 5.3 around there
so since I was only putting in another
2.4 into what i already had of 2.3 i
wasn't going to make about 600 k on this
merge which he's one of my more
successful merchants of the series and
is definitely helpful towards where
we're at at the moment however this is
pretty much the end of the merchant for
the video and now i'm going to show you
guys a state that i did the account is
one of my friends accounts i'm pretty
sure my main account literally just
rigged to not let me win and it's weird
to say that but trust me I I legitimate
Lee feel that way and I feel as if I
have a decent enough amount of proof as
to why but as you can see this we were
going in for 20 mil stake i actually i
pitted it out and it was it was well I
don't know I'm just I never win
legitimate stakes it's kind of a sad
thing but there we go I want 20 ml
because Sophia's made it this far
obviously congratulate you basically
this video setups a little weird in the
amount of time it took me to make this
video is also a little strange I was
changing households and I'm not really
sure yet how I want to record this I was
kind of being lazy at the time of
recording and I was I want and I pretty
much told myself and like I'll go back
through later and i'll put commentary on
all of this and it's I I don't think it
makes it fun of a video if you guys
think differently feel free to let me
know however this is where we are now
there's a lot of time that's gone by
since my last
it but trust me it's all been merging
and guarantee that anyways we're gonna
price check this all and this is how
much i currently have so the OS buddy
guide price obviously wrong it's not you
under 21 k nonetheless it's not that
high it's about 500 k less so right now
we're about 9.3 mill and I think that's
we're going to where we are going to end
off the video i want to start uploading
these a lot more frequently a lot of
people do series like this and they do
like a day pretty much as far as merging
and then upload that as a video i'd like
to keep it to one or two days of merging
and then upload that so you guys think
that that's cool feel free to let me
know nonetheless hope you guys enjoyed
the video and if you made it this far
trust me i'm more than appreciative of
it and hope you guys have a wonderful
day so peace out guys and i will see you
guys in the next video